the ouster chairman of Nissan has fled
Japan where he was awaiting trial for
financial crimes carlos dong has fled
house arrest in tokyo i want to turn to
Carlos Goins Great Escape how on earth
did Carlos go to make his escape without
a passport and while he was under house
arrest how could someone under such
heavy surveillance possibly escape from
trial in a sophisticated high-tech
country like Japan and yet it was
possible because that's exactly what
occurred I'm Matthew Campbell I'm a
reporter for Bloomberg Businessweek
based in Singapore and I wrote the Tokyo
job a story about Carlos Khan's
daring escape from Tokyo Carlos Cohen
has been one of the big names in the
auto industry for the better part of 20
years he was a kind of legendary
turnaround artist dispatched to Nissan
by Renault he is Lebanese by descent
however he was born in Brazil and moved
to Lebanon with his parents of a child
grew up largely in Lebanon but then went
to France to continue his education and
from there he was sort of launched into
the corporate world working at Michelin
how the tire company and then eventually
at Renault when Gaughan was sent to
Nissan in 1999 it it looked like a
suicide mission
this was a company that just could not
be in worse shape but nobody wanted its
cars it had a incredibly complicated
management structure it was producing
too many models huge amounts of debt he
started simplifying everything he cut
costs everywhere he could and sure
enough
Nissan returned to profit it returned to
health it started growing again and he
eventually turned it into the core of
this global Empire the the
renault-nissan Alliance that then came
to incorporate other car makers in
Russia and
Mitsubishi in Japan and to be one of the
two or three dominant automotive groups
in the world this year is gonna be
another record year for the industry so
I came on to this story after this
shocking series of events that took
place in November 2018 when gone was
suddenly arrested in Tokyo on the on the
tarmac just about at Haneda Airport
where he just arrived on his corporate
jet welcome back breaking news in the
past few minutes Nissan has revealed
that its chairman has been arrested
after allegations of serious misconduct
Goins arrest initially was on on a
somewhat peculiar charge what he was
accused of was making false statements
in financial disclosures to leave out
compensation that he was going to
receive he has said that this
compensation that prosecutors say was
not disclosed was in fact hypothetical
it was never finalized and indeed he
never received any of the money which is
not in dispute but then over time there
were three more charges another to do
with compensation and then two more that
alleged he had misused Nissan's
resources in in dealings in the Middle
East and in ways that lined his own
pocket or got em out of financial jams
on these third and fourth charges ago
and of course denies wrongdoing says he
acted properly and that the prosecutors
are just making up allegations out of
thin air you know this is such a lie
from the beginning to the end now so
that was the legal backdrop the
corporate backdrop though was that there
were real tensions at Nissan between
gone and some of the other executives
particularly Japanese executives who
were concerned that a plan he was
working on to more closely integrate
Nissan and Renault under one corporate
umbrella might diminish Nissan's
independence might make it an arm of a
French company and and that was the
backdrop in which Nissan actually began
actively investigating him
in the spring of 2018 without guns
knowledge of course and eventually
passing its findings on to prosecutors
and those findings then became the basis
of the criminal charges against him and
then he stayed in jail I believe the
figure was 108 days in solitary
confinement before he was finally given
bail before trial and released he was
out for a little while a little under a
month I believe and he ends up back in
jail for a little while he was then
released again on bail but under very
strict supervision not allowed to leave
Japan of course tailed at all times by
plainclothes agents he was not allowed
to use the internet except under
supervision at his lawyer's office he
had been fired and cut off from his
family so gone was was in a strange sort
of limbo for a guy who had been on top
of the world for so long it must have
been incredibly Jarre
there's no question it is very very
difficult to defend yourself in a
Japanese court he was looking at very
long odds to clear his name and to stay
out of prison the maximum he was looking
at would have been 15 years to one and a
half times the longest penalty is the
rule but this is a guy who's in his
sixties was looking at a potentially a
very very long time behind bars and and
well into his old age
[Music]
hello I spoke to a security contractor
in Asia who had gotten a mysterious call
sometime last year asking if he knew
anyone who would be available to ask or
to VIP out of the country in Japan he
wanted to know what they were getting
into but the person on the other end of
the line didn't want to tell him
anything or didn't know and so they kind
of dropped it and the contractor I spoke
to never really thought about this again
until of course like the rest of the
world he he saw the news that Carlos
gone and somehow gotten out of Japan
yeah boy what a twist this is right at
the end of the year the last day of 2019
and Carlos going pulls this escape act
and my initial reaction was just shock
and disbelief it seemed so cinematic it
was it was something from fiction that
he could possibly have done this of
course he did
[Music]
there was a team of ex military and ex
police operatives who were working on
these scenarios trying things out
investigating airports and other ports
of entry and eggs and in Japan looking
for vulnerabilities looking for a way to
do this they mustn't be seen talking
together go back to church into the
woods into the woods you understand the
person who ran this team who was in
charge was named Michael Taylor he is an
American he was born in Staten Island
joined the army out of high school and
ended up in the Green Berets so he was a
very elite soldier notably he was
deployed to Lebanon during the Lebanese
civil war and that began a pretty long
association with Lebanon and
particularly with the Christian
community and Lebanon which is of course
the community that gowned himself as a
member of if you were looking for
someone with the profile pull off a job
like this he was the right kind of guy
you had to get a very recognizable
person out of the center of one of the
biggest cities in the world somehow to
an airport somehow onto an airplane all
without being caught
and the team who were helping gone
noticed something intriguing that when
he entered a hotel the people who were
tailing him would drop away or wait when
he entered a hotel why we don't know so
that was something that they thought
they could exploit now when the time
came gone simply walked out the front
door of his house
[Music]
he was wearing a surgical mask the kind
you wear for germs or pollution he then
went to a big hotel the Grand Hyatt and
Roppongi which has quite a few entrances
and exits it's quite a confusing place
and from there he made his way to
Shinagawa station
one of the main rail hubs for Tokyo and
a very busy place where you could easily
just blend into the crowd after that he
was on a speed train to Osaka Japan's
second city even if he had been seen
that wouldn't in itself have been a huge
problem gone was permitted to travel
within Japan and from there he went to
Kansai Airport the main International
Airport for Osaka so gonna piers to have
been loaded onto this plane in Osaka in
a big box the kind if you've ever seen
Rodan setting up for a big concert that
is how he was concealed that's how the
people escorting him were able to evade
an x-ray at a Kansai Airport because the
box was far too big for the scanners the
plane flew about 12 hours to Istanbul
atatürk Airport where they were matched
by an employee of the company they had
chartered the plane from this employee
then helped transfer going from this
first plane which had arrived from Osaka
to a second plane nearby which would
take him on to Beirut Cohen
got on that plane shortly after and and
later that morning he was safely in
Beirut now I'm going to be able to speak
with facts and data and evidence and
hopefully you will discover the truth
goons position really from the beginning
was that he was the victim of a coup
that there were nationalist factions at
Nissan within the Japanese government
who wanted him gone who objected to his
plans to integrate Nissan and Renault
under a single holding company and who
had decided that to get rid of him they
needed to for lack of a better term find
some dirt fine
something that they could use to
dislodge him the whole thing was
applauded
Japan has issued what's called a red
notice in gongs name and that's a sort
of wanted poster that goes out through
Interpol the global federation of police
agencies however lebanon as a policy
does not extradite its citizens so the
the outcome of this process is pretty
much preordained he's not going to be
extradited from Lebanon what could of
course occur would be a trial in Lebanon
that the Japanese allegations would be
tried in Lebanon Gaughan has said he's
happy to face trial anywhere where he
believes such a trial would be fair that
obviously in his view excludes Japan the
difference between gone and other
criminal defendants whether Japan or
elsewhere is frankly money this is a guy
who had very significant financial
resources who had connections all over
the world he was drawing multiple
salaries and he had multiple jobs he was
the chairman of Nissan he was the
chairman and CEO of Renault he was also
the chairman of Mitsubishi which was the
third major arm of their Global Alliance
but gone you know making 10 15 million
dollars a year was by far the highest
paid person in Japan you know country
where even top business executives tend
to be paid relatively modestly it did
rankle some people for sure
[Music]
gone is in Lebanon with his family he is
in a country where he's comfortable
where he knows lots of people and could
spend as much time as he wants probably
living a quiet life there but I don't
think that's what going wants I think he
he craves an indication he wants to have
a comeback and so while he's kind of
gone quiet in the last little while I
don't think we've heard the last of him
at all
you